في الأربعين عامًا التي انقضت منذ أن بدأ pac-man لأول مرة
عبر شاشاتنا
، خرجت صناعة الألعاب من الأروقة وأصبحت ألعاب
[الموسيقى]
هذه ظاهرة عالمية بمليارات الدولارات
[تصفيق]
هذه ليست صناعة صغيرة  هذه
صناعة ضخمة وسيزداد حجمها فقط
كما تعلم ، أعني أن هناك شركات
تنسحب من Super Bowl الآن
وتضع أموالها في الرياضات الإلكترونية
والألعاب التي تخبرك بشيء ما أليس
كذلك ، إنه أمر لا يصدق أن شركة Goldman sachs
تستثمر فيه Merrill Lynch
يستثمرون فيه ، لذا فهو هنا
للتأكد من الأرق ، حيث يقام مهرجان ألعاب
سنوي في دبي لأول مرة لاستكشاف
واحدة من أسرع المناطق نموًا في
صناعة الألعاب ، شعرنا بوجود
فجوة في السوق حيث كان اللاعبون هنا
لا يوجد  سؤال حول هذه الألعاب الضخمة ،
وهي إحدى صناعات الألعاب الأسرع نموًا
في العالم ،
والتي كانت في يوم من الأيام عالمًا للمهوسين
والمهووسين ، تدور الآن حول
رعاة الشركات الكبرى والكثير من
المال واللاعبون يصرفون أموالًا بنعم ، فنحن في
الواقع نريد الكثير من الأموال في
البطولات وقد حصلنا عليها في وقت سابق من هذا
العام ، وقد احتل الأمريكي كايل أيريس ، البالغ من العمر 16 عامًا ،
عناوين الصحف عندما فاز بثلاثة
ملايين دولار في دورة أسبوعين
[موسيقى]
فاز الشاب بها  ثلاثة ملايين ولكن
كان هذا هو الفائز الأخير فقط ، فقد كان إجمالي
صندوق الجائزة ثلاثين مليون دولار ،
تخيل أنه ليس مجرد جائزة
مالية ، فقد أصبحت الألعاب طريقًا إلى
وظائف في تصميم البرمجيات
والهندسة ، يمكنهم كسب المال في
صناعة الألعاب كثيرًا  من المال في
صناعة الألعاب لكنهم قد يختارون
مسارًا مختلفًا وهناك مجالات
يمكنك الحصول على شهادة في الألعاب
الآن وهي مسار سريع لبعض
أكبر الوظائف في العالم الآن أعني أن
Google توظف من صناعة الألعاب
أكثر  من هؤلاء المراهقين ليسوا
قلقين بشأن المستقبل في الوقت الحالي
فهم يعيشون اللحظة
ويشاهدون هواية طفولتهم
تتحول إلى فرصة لكسب المال
آنا  ستيوارت سي إن إن